[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم انا صهيب شراير وهذه العربيه 360
الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
بعد عثوره على اليورانيوم المختفي الجيش
الليبي يرجح تورط مسلحين شاديين ويتهموا
وكاله الطاقه بالتقاعس
واشنطن قد تشتري الذخيره من سول وتمررها
الجديده في اوروبا
الرياض تامل ان ينعكس الاتفاق مع طهران
ايجابا على المنطقه وتؤكد قيامه على
احترام السياده وحل الخلافات سلميه
لدينا ايضا في 360
اذا نتابع معكم الكريم يربط انتشار حطام
مسيره البحر الاسود
باحتياجات الامن القومي واحكام الجغرافيا
تعجز واشنطن
[موسيقى]
عقب اعلان الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
عن فقدان طنين ونصف الطن من اليورانيوم
المخزنه في احد المواقع في ليبيا كشف
الجيش الليبيا ان قوه تابعه لها عثرت على
الكميه المفقوده من اليورانيوم بالقرب من
الحدود التشاديه وحمل بيان الجيش الليبي
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه المسؤوليه
عن الحادثه
اللواء خالد المحجوب الامين العام للقياده
العامه للجيش الليبي كشف ان الحاويات وجدت
في نقطه باتجاه الحدود التشاديه على بعد
خمسه كيلومترات فقط من المستودع الذي كان
[__] البراميل والذي رجح التقارير انه في
مدينه سبها وانتقد المحجوب وكاله الطاقه
بدعوى انها فتشت الموقع في عام 2020
وجردت ما فيه من محتويات ثم اغلقت بابه
بالشمع الاحمر واوضح ان الوكاله تعهدت في
ذلك الوقت بتوفير احتياجات الحراسه التي
تشمل ملابس خاصه وكمامات وغيرها لحمايه
الافراد من اي اخطار المحجوب قال ان
الوكاله لم تفي بتعهداتها ما دفع الحراس
لمراقبه المستودع من نقطه بعيده خوفا من
الاخطار وبحسب المحجوب فان جماعات المسلحه
شاديه ربما استغلت الوضع واستولت على
البراميل لكنها كانت تجهل طبيعه الماده
الموجوده فيها فتركتها
[موسيقى]
وفي اول خطاب يلقيها امام اقطاب الاعمال
منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا قال بوتين ان
بلاده تواجهه حرب عقوبات وانها تمكنت من
تعويض اغلاق الاسواق الغربيه امامها واضاف
بوتين ان روسيا تعيد توجيها دفه اقتصادها
بسرعه نحو الدول التي لم تستهدفها
بالعقوبات معتبرا ان منطقه اليورو تحاول
اقناع الجميع بما وصفه بشائعات الانهيار
الوشيك للاقتصاد الروسي والتضخم المرتفع
قلت وسائل الاعلام الغربيه نوار لجات الى
مخازن ذخيرتها في الخارج لمساعدتك في
الاستعداد لهجومها المضاد خلال الربيع حيث
بدات واشنطن سحب ذخيره من مواقع في
اسرائيل والمانيا وكوريا الجنوبيه اذ تعرف
هذه المواقع بالمواقع الجاهزه والهدف منها
تزويد القوات الامريكيه في جميع انحاء
العالم بالذخيره كما تتفاوض واشنطن مع صول
لشراء ذخيره منها لحساب كيف
هذا واقل المستشار الالماني انه من المهم
جدا تامين الذخائر بسرعه لاوكرانيا من اجل
التصدي للغزو الروسي داعيا الشركاء
الاوروبيين لايجاد تدابير جديده بهذا
الخصوص
سنستمر مع شركائنا الاوروبيين في ضمان
حصول اوكرانيا على اسلحه ومعدات للصمود
والدفاع عن نفسها من المهم تزويد اوكرانيا
بالذخيره اللازمه بسرعه في المجلس
الاوروبي وجمبا الى جنب مع شركائنا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي سنتفق على المزيد من
الاجراءات لتحقيق امدادات افضل وبشكل
مستمر ونحن مستعدون لفتح مشاريع المشتريات
في المانيا للدول الاعضاء ايضا
نتابع من فريق مع الدكتور محمد سيف الدين
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه دكتور محمد
اهلا بكم معنا لماذا تسارع اوروبا الخطى
من اجل تزويد اوكرانيا
بالمزيد من الاسلحه
بدايه اوروبا مستمره بالنهج الذي اعتمدته
منذ نحو العام هي ضمن التحالف الغربي تريد
التعبير عن يعني دعمها لاوكرانيا وهي
تتخوف ايضا وقد خوفت يعني بشكل مقصود في
السنوات الماضيه وخصوصا في السنه الاخيره
من روسيا ومن دخول الروس بنفوزهم
وبالاعتماد على الغاز الروسي داخل داخل
اوروبا الان اوروبا تشعر بانها تريد ان
تساهم في هذا النصر اذا صح تعبيره اذا اذا
ما تحقق لاوكرانيا وان تعبر عن طريقتها
لحمايه امنها وفي الوقت نفسه تتنافس
للحصول على الموارد التي تاتي من هذا من
هذا الاطار نعم طيب ولكن دكتور محمد الم
يطل هذا النصر المنتظر الغربي في اوكرانيا
بالتاكيد لقد طال وليس من الواضح ما اذا
كان ممكنا يعني هناك الكثير من المعطيات
التي تشير الى استحاله
المعركه المشتعله الان في باخموتيه من
اكثر من سته اشهر والقوات الاوكرانيه هناك
تعاني يعني امام القوات الروسيه ومجموعه
هناك التي تحاصر باخمت
هذا الجزء الصغير من المواجهه الجزء
الاكبر هو ما نراه اليوم في البنوك
الاوروبيه وفي البنوك الامريكيه وفي
التراجع الاقتصادي وفي زياده معدلات تضخم
وفي معاناه البنوك الفيدراليه والبنوك
المركزيه في معالجه هذه هذه الامور وفي
الصراع على الموارد وفي الصراع داخل
التحالفات وداخل الحلف الواحد الان فرنسا
تحاول مثلا ان يعني تشد المصالح الى الى
جانبها تحاول ان تبيع الاسلحه من جانبها
تحاول الحصول على صفقات تحاول الحصول على
طاقه رخيصه كما كانت قبل هذا العام قبل
الدخول الروسي الى الى اوكرانيا المانيا
ايضا تحاول النجاه بنفسها الولايات
المتحده تحاول سحب رؤوس الاموال من اوروبا
لمعالجه مشكلات التضخم والازمه الماليه
المقبله هناك صراع داخل التحالف ايضا على
كل هذه كل هذه التفاصيل وبموازاه ذلك لا
تبدو النتائج التي تتحقق في الميدان
للقوات الاوكرانيه بانها باتجاه انتصار
ميداني يمكن ان ينتشر كل التحالف ويحقق
فوائد للجميع هذا الامر لا يبدو متحققا
حتى الان خصوصا مع تطورات عالميه اكثر
عمقا واكثر ارتفاعا لها علاقه بالدول
الصاعده
وبتمرد الكثير من القوى على سيطره التحالف
الغربي على العلاقات الدوليه دكتور محمد
ارجو ان تتفضل بالبقاء معنا ساعود اليك في
زاويه اخرى بعد استعراض التقرير التالي
مشاهدينا خطط الاتحاد الاوروبي لدعم
اوكرانيا بالسلاح باتت تواجه معضله بسبب
مطالب قدمتها فرنسا في اجتماع للاتحاد في
بروكسيل فرنسا مشاهدينا وبحسب تقرير
لصحيفه تيليغرافي البريطانيه متهمه بتاخير
خطه الاتحاد الاوروبي البالغه ملياري يورو
لتجديد مخزون قذائف المدفعيه الاوكرانيه
مصادر اوروبيه قالت ان باريس تريد ضمانات
بان صفقه هذه الاسلحه التي تبلغ
اسلحه بشكل مشترك ستفيد فقط الشركات
الموجوده في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي الاتحاد
يجري حاليا محادثات لشراء مليون قذيفه
مدفعيه من عيار 155 ملم لدعم اوكرانيا
وايضا لملئ مستودعات الاسلحه الاوروبيه
المستنفذه وحتى الان لم تزود دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي اوكرانيا الا ب 30000 قذيفه
مدفعيه من هذا العيار كما سدد الاتحاد
للدول الاعضاء
450 مليون يورو مقابل التبرعات المقدمه
لاوكرانيا وبواقع يورو فاصل 28 عن كل
قذيفه متبرع بها ميدانيا على الارض تطلق
القوات الاوكرانيه ما يقدر بنحو سته الاف
طلقه مدفعيه كل يوم وفقا للمخابرات
الغربيه بينما قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
في اجتماع مع نظرائه الاوروبيين ان
اوكرانيا تحتاج لمئه الف طلقه مدفعيه
شهريا لتخفيف النقص في ساحه المعركه
وفي الجهه المقابله روسيا تطلق 20,000
قذيفه في اليوم وهي ذات الكميه التي
يصنعها المنتجون الاوروبيون وهنا اعود الى
ضيفي اذا من باريس دكتور محمد فرنسا تريد
ان تكون دفعه او حزمه الاسلحه الجديده
التي تذهب الى اوكرانيا من الذخائر مصنعه
في منطقه اليورو لماذا هذا الاصرار
الفرنسي دكتور محمد
في البدايه هذا الاسرار يعبر يعبر عن ميل
فرنسي متجذر ويعبر عنه مره بعد اخرى في
مختلف الميادين وهو الميل الى استقلاليه
اوروبيه وسياده اوروبيه ويبقى هذا الميل
تحت سقف التوجه الامريكي العام لان فرنسا
لا تمتلك مقدار القوه الذي تمتلكه
الولايات المتحده ولا تمتلك نفس الوسائل
ونفس القدره على احداث هذه الضغوط وحمايه
موقفها السيادي لكن دائما تعبر عن هذا
الشيء الان في هذه اللحظه وفي اطار ما
يجري وما ذكرناه سابقا فرنسا تحاول
الاستفاده من التجارب السابقه هي تعرضت
تعتبر انها تعرضت للطعن في صفقه الغواصات
مع استراليا تعتبر انها
ان اوروبا كلها تتعرض لافراغ من قدراتها
وابتلي سوف تكون يتم خلق حاجه لتكون في
المستقبل بحاجه الى استيراد اسلحه من من
اماكن اخرى وهذا الامر يضاف الى زياده
زياده الانفاق على الميزانيات الدفاعيه ان
كان في المانيا او ان كان في في فرنسا
وبالتالي هناك حاجه تتبلور لمزيد من
استخدام الاسلحه الى اوروبا اذا لم تكن
هذه الاسلحه من صناعات اوروبيه ولشركات
اوروبيه في فرنسا والمانيا فهذا سيخلق
تبعيه على المدى الطويل للقاره باكملها
تحديدا للولايات المتحديدا
فرنسا تريد لاوروبا ان تبتعد عن الفلك
الامريكي او ان تكون لها حصتها كذلك والا
تكون الفائده امريكيه فقط ولكن فرنسا هنا
متهمه الان بابطاء ايصال الدعم العسكري
الى اوكرانيا في سبيل النصر الذي تحدثنا
انه تاخر كثيرا للاوكرانيين
نعم اذا دققنا في الموقف الفرنسي وقد
تحدثنا سابقا في مقابلات على شاشتكم عن
هذا الامر اذا دققنا تحديدا في الموقف
الفرنسي في عمق هذا هذا الموقف منذ اندلاع
هذه المواجهه في اوكرانيا لم تكن فرنسا
ترغب بان تصل هذه المواجهه الى هذا الحد
الذي وصلت اليه وهي وانتماشت يعني شاركت
في كل الجهود الغربيه لمواجهه روسيا كانت
تفضل ان لا تصل الامور الى هذا الحد وان
يحافظ على خيط تواصل او على باب مفتوح مع
يعني القياده الروسيه وقد قام الرئيس
الفرنسي بالكثير من الجهود في الفتره
الاولى للمواجهه بهذا بهذا الاتجاه
وبالتالي التوجه الفرنسي العام لا يميل
الى ادامه هذا الخلاف وادامه هذه المواجهه
لان فرنسا تدرك اكثر من غيرها بان من يدفع
الفاتوره الاولى والاقصى في هذه المواجهه
هو الاتحاد الاوروبي ككل وليس الولايات
المتحده وليس روسيا لان روسيا ايضا
يعني بدائل عن عن عن
المشكلات التي حصلت لها وعمال خسيرته من
هذه الحرب شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور محمد سيف
الدين انت البحث في العلاقات الدوليه كنت
معنا مباشره من باريس ومشاهدينا في باريس
نبقى ونذهب الى الان الى هذه الصور
المباشره اذا التي فردنا في التوبه اللحظه
الشرطه بدات
بتفريق المحتجين امام مقر البرلمان
الفرنسي الذين طبعا يحتاجون منذ فتره ليس
الان ولكن البرلمان
يستعد لتمرير قانون التقاعد رفع سن
التقاعد في فرنسا من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما
كما نتابع في هذه الصور في محيط مقر
البرلمان الفرنسي قوات مكافحه الشغب تبعد
المتظاهرين
الفرنسيين وكما نتابع هناك
تدخل واستخدام للعنف لابعاد هؤلاء
المتظاهرين كما نتابع في هذه الصور من
باريس من محيط البرلمان الفرنسي طبعا هم
يجرون جرا
هذه المتظاهره طبعا اعود واذكر بانه تم
اقرار القانون اذا تمريره من قبل البرلمان
الفرنسي رفع سن التقاعد في فرنسا طبعا ما
زاد من غضب المحتجين على هذا الاصلاح الذي
اصر عليها رئيس الفرنسي طبعا
صوت اطلاق ربما قنابل مسيله للدموع لتفريق
المحتجين طبعا كانت هناك معارضه كبيره في
الشارع الفرنسي مظاهرات استمرت
لاسابيع طويله هي ايضا هي احتجاجات اذا
على تمرير الحكومه الفرنسيه
لقانون رفع سن التقاعد في فرنسا من 62
عاما الى 64 عاما في فرنسا
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا كمان نتابع معكم هذه الصور
من باريس حيث تقوم الشرطه ايضا بالتدخل
وقوات مكافحه الشغب بالفرنسيه كذلك لابعاد
المحتجين الرافدين لقانون التقاعد الجديد
في فرنسا
بعد تمريره من قبل
الحكومه الفرنسيه طبعا رفع
نظام التقاعد او سن التقاعد من 62 عاما
الى 64 عاما هي خطوه يعني تثير غضب الكثير
من الفرنسيين قطاع واسع ولكن الحكومه
الفرنسيه والرئيس
اصر على مشروعه مشروع اصلاح نظام التقاعد
وطبعا كان في وقت سابق طبعا قرر الرئيس
ماكرون الذهاب الى تصويت في الجمعيه
الوطنيه على مشروعه لاصلاح نظام التقاعد
الذي كما نتابع معكم هو ما يزال يثير
موجه كبيره من الاحتجاجات في فرنسا
واضطرابات عارمه
اذا سنبقى في مراقبه هذا الموقف وتطورات
ما يحصل اذا في باريس من هذه الاحتجاجات
على تمرير قانون رفع سن التقاعد فيه فرنسا
[موسيقى]
اكد المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جون كيربي ان قرار بولندا بارسال
مقاتلات تسعه وعشرين الى اوكرانيا لا يغير
الموقف الامريكي المعارض لارسال طائراتنا
امريكيه الصنع الى كييف كما اعتبر كيربي
ان المحادثات بين الرئيسين الاوكراني
والصيني ستكون امرا جيدا
وكان رئيس البولندي كشف ان بلاده تعتزم
ارسال اربع طائرات مقاتله من 29 الى
اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى طائرات اخرى بعد
الانتهاء من صيانتها
[موسيقى]
كخطوه الاولى في الايام القليله المقبله
سنرسل اربع طائرات مقاتله من طراز ميج
تسعه وعشرين تعمل بكامل طاقتها الى
اوكرانيا اما الطائرات الاخرى التي تخضع
حاليا للصيانه والعمل سننجح في ارسالها
الى اوكرانيا لاحقا
نشر فريق تحقيق الاممي تقريرا قال فيه ان
نقل اطفال اوكرانيين الى المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطره موسكو في اوكرانيا والى روسيا يشكل
جريمه حرب واضاف المحققون في تقريرهم ان
مهاجمه روسيا البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
واستخدام التعذيب قد يشكل جرائم ضد
الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
خلصت اللجنه الى ان السلطات الروسيه
ارتكبت انتهاكات عديده للقانون الانساني
الدولي والقانون الدولي لحقوق الانسان
بالاضافه الى مجموعه واسعه من جرائم الحرب
بما في ذلك جريمه الحرب المتمثله في القتل
العرضي والقتل العمد والتعذيب والمعامله
اللا انسانيه والحبس غير القانوني
والاغتصاب اضافه للنقل والترحيل بصوره غير
قانونيه
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا نعود الى موضوعنا الاول في
العربيه 360 هذه الليله وهو موضوع فقدان
طنين ونصف الطن من اليورانيوم من احد
المخازن في ليبيا والعثور عليها قرب
الحدود مع تشاد حول هذا الموضوع معنا من
القاهره المحلل السياسي ابراهيم بلقاسم
استاذ ابراهيم اهلا بك معنا المحجوب تكهن
ان مجموعه من تشاد داهمت المستودع واخذت
براميل اليورانيوم املا في ان يكون بها
اسلحه او ذخيره لكنها تركتها بعدما لم تجد
الذخيره فيها هل يفسر هذا ما حدث
اهلا بك حقيقه ايا كانت المبررات هناك
مسالتين خطيرات الاولى ان الكميه التي تم
الوصول اليها ليس فقط الاستيلاء عليها
وتهريبها من المواقع المفترض انها مؤمنه
من المجموعه التي تؤمن الجنوب الان
وابعادها وصولها الى الحدود التشاديه
مجموعات من المرتزقه استسهلوا او كان
لديهم القدره على الوصول الى
ما هو ما المفترض من الخطوط الحمراء
بالنسبه لليبيا لقد تجر على ليبيا الولاد
هذه المساله خطيره جدا الكميه التي عثر
عليها كميه تكفي لصناعه
على الاقل فالكميه ليست بسيطه كميه كبيره
نتكلم عن اثنين ونص طن اعتقد ان مهما كانت
الاشكاليه ان كانت هناك تراخي عدم القدره
على التامين بشكل احادي ان كان هناك
مرتزقه يتمادون ولديهم القدره عن الوصول
الى ابعد من مجرد الخطوط الحمراء في ليبيا
او ان كانت هناك عدم اكتراث وعدم اهتمام
بملفات كثيره جدا من بين اليورانيوم لان
هذا ملف خطير جدا ملف وخطوره هذا الملف
استاذ ابراهيم هناك هناك اتهامات اخرى
يعني روايه اخرى تتحدث على انه بعد
الاطاحه بنظام القذافي كان هناك دول سعه
للحصول على مخزون ليبيا من اليورانيوم
والكعكه الصفراء من بينها ايران يعني
استغلت الفوضى التي دخلت فيها ليبيا بعد
سقوط نظام القذافي
وذهبت الى هناك الى اي حد يمكن ان يكون
هذا ايضا تفسيرا اخر انه ممكن يكونوا
تكونوا عناصر ايرانيه وصلت الى مخزون
ليبيا من اليورانيوم
حتى اكون معك واضح كانت هناك ثلاث تساؤلات
بخصوص هذا ملف تحديدا منذ سقوط النظام
الاولى كيف ستتعامل السلطه الجديده ما بعد
عام 2011 او السلطه الثوره مع ما بقى من
مخزون للريال اليورانيوم في ليبيا بعد ان
سلم جزء منه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عبر وكاله
الذريه وكاله الطاقه الى عام 2005 كان
عليهم كان كانوا يحتاجون الى سؤال واضح
كيف سيتعامل مع هذا الملف الثانيه هو
مساله كيف
ستحافظ
السلطات الليبيه على المخطوطات الفنيه
التي لها علاقه بالتقسيط وكيف ستتعامل مع
المسؤولين على او الفنيين الليبيين
المسؤولين على التخصيب في يوم من الايام
كانت هذه التساؤلات واضحه جدا للاسف فعلا
كان الى حد ما هناك اشبه من صراعات ظل حول
هذا ملف في داخل ليبيا او حول ليبيا صراحه
لا احد يعني ينكر كانت هناك مساعي فرنسيه
حقيقيه وتواجد فرنسا من الاساس في له
علاقه باكداس اليورانيوم الخام الموجوده
تحت جبال اوكاكوس او ان الى حد ما كان
الايرانيين يسعون الى حتى عام 2015 عندما
تسلل او كانت هناك تقارير تتحدث عن تسلل
عدد من الحارس الثوري الايراني الى جنوب
ليبيا واستهدف من قوه اخرى معاديه لايران
في داخل ليبيا وكان هناك قتال اقليمي في
داخل ليبيا على اراضي ليبيا وعلى ملفات
جدا بالنسبه هو موضوع جدا
نتحدث عن كميه ليست بالقليله كما تفضلت
طنين ونصف من اليورانيوم
وكما تفضلت البرنامج النووي الليبي ايام
القذافي كان وصل بعيدا الى ان اوقفه في
عام 2003 بعد
الغزو الامريكي للعراق
وبحجه طبعا منع العراق او بحجه امتلاك
العناق لاسلحه الدمار الشامل لكن ملف هذا
يعيدنا الان الى عن مخزون ليبيا يعني الى
اين وصل البرنامج النووي اللي بي اليوم
ماذا نعرف عن هذا البرنامج اليوم والى اين
وصل
هذا السؤال خطير جدا صراحه الاجابه على
السؤال قد تكلف
المجيب الكثير حتى يعني يعني هناك يعني
الواضح من من الحادثه انه هناك برنامج
نووي ليبي وصل بعيدا وهو ما يزال
تقدم برنامج وهو موضوع خطير لانه نقل
البراميل
في تلك المنطقه وهذا يعني اثره سيبقى
لاجيال
ومخاطره من الاشعاع النووي والصحي كذلك هل
هذه الحادثه ستستدعي تدخل الدوليا
هذا ما سيحدث بشكل فعلي الان قدمت
المبررات للقوه الدوليه التي تحاول ان تجد
مبررات اكثر
للتواجد بشكل فعلي اكبر في الجنوب او
لتحميل هذا الملف لخصومها سياسيين انتظر
الان ان يحمل الموضوع على سبيل المثال
مرتزقهم ضد الانسانيه يمارسوا كل شيء لكن
من الصعب تقدير ان هذه المجموعه مرتبطه
بشكل مباشر صحيح ان المعارضه التشاديه
الغير منتظمه الموجوده في جنوب ليبيا التي
وصلت الى هذه
النقاط الحساسه جدا وصولها الى براميل
النفط تدربت على يد الفاغنر في يوم من
الايامات بل وصلت الى قتلت رئيس تشاد في
لحظه من لحظات ادريس دبي فاعتقد ان نعم
هناك اتصالات هناك صراع دولي سينعكس مره
اخرى كنوع من تصفيه الحسابات اخشى يا صهيب
صراحه ان مثل هذه الاخطاء التي ترتكب الان
من اطراف عده سواء كانت ليبيه او غير
ليبيه قد تجلب على ليبيا ويلات اكثر خصوصا
ان هذه ملفات حساسه جدا صحيح جنوب هناك
تواجد للفار هناك تواجد لمجموعات اخرى لا
نرغب في اي لحظه من اللحظات ان نرى ليبيا
اوكرانيا ثانيه لا نرى لا نرغب في ان
تستمر حاله التمادي والصراعات والتقاطعات
في داخل ليبيا من القوه الدوليه حتى
تستخدمنا مره اخرى لحلب من حاله الحروف
بالوكاله او لتصفيه او المعالج خلافاتها
في داخلها على كل هذا الملف ملف خطير نعم
ليبيا كانت متقدمه فيه بشكل كبير لكن في
لحظه ما توقف الملف انسحبت ليبيا سلمت ما
يمكن تسليمه الباقي المفترض انه تم
معالجته في اطار اتفاقات كثيره جدا
رئيس جهاز المخابرات الاستخبارات
الامريكيه اليوم كان جزء من اتفاقات بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وليبيا في
ملفات عده من بين هذه الملفات الملف
النووي الليبي الليبي في حد ذاته اعتقد
هذا الملف اغلق لكن الان التنبيس عليه
ربما قد يعيدنا مره اخرى وهذا يعني ان
هناك بعض الدول
خطير جدا يعني الحقيقه نعم اكيد يعني تكون
له تفاعلات كبيره لاحقا شكرا جزيلا لك
ابراهيم القاسم انت المحلل السياسي اللي
بيك كنت معنا من القاهره
في العربيه 360 بعد قليل
اثيوبيا ترفض تصريحات المصريه عن الحلول
المفتوحه في ازمه سد النهضه وتقول ان الحد
ان الحل الودي ممكن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى العربيه 360 قال
الكلام لان الجيش الروسي سيعمل على انتشال
حطام المسيره الامريكيه من قاع البحر
الاسود اذا اعتبر ذلك ضروريا للامن القومي
اما البيت الابيض فاكد استمرار عمليه
الاستطلاع فوق البحر الاسود دعما
لاوكرانيا
واسقاط القوات الجويه الروسيه لمسيره
امريكيه فوق البحر الاسود اعاد تسليط
الضوء على
الضوء على هذا البحر المشاهدين اذا وصراع
القوى الدوليه عليه والتوتر في هذا البحر
ليس بالجديد ودائما ما كان نقطه ساخنه بين
روسيا من جانب الدول الغربيه من جهه اخرى
معكم بشكل اكبر على البحر الاسود ست دول
تشاطئه نصفها اعضاء في النيتو وهي تركيا
رومانيا بلغاريا اضافه لاوكرانيا القريبه
من الحلف وكل من روسيا وجورجيا الوجود
البحريه الروسي هو الاكبر في البحر الاسود
ولموسكو قاعدتان الاولى هي قاعده
نوبوسيسك والاخرى في شبه جزيره القرم
وتحديدا في ميناء سيفاستوبل اسطول البحر
الاسود الروسي يضم سفنا حربيه صغيره
وزوارق قتاليه وسفن انزال وكاسحات الغام
اضافه لغواصات هجينه تعمل بالكهرباء
والديزل وطائرات حامله للصواريخ المضاده
للطائرات والغواصات الاسطول الشماليه
التركي المتمركز في البحر الاسود يضم
بدوره ايضا مقاتلات ومروحيات وغواصات
وكاسات الغام وسفن مقاتله لتركيا نفود
كبير على البحر الاسود يتمثل في سيطرتها
على مضيقي البوسفور
المؤديين للبحر وبامكانها اغلاق المضيقين
امام حركه المرور العسكريه في اوقات الحرب
بعيدا عن تركيا وبخلاف الاسطولين التركي
والروسي تمتلك رومانيا وبلغاريا قوات
بحريه اصغر فيما لا يوجد في جورجيا سوى
خفر سواحل للبحر الاسود
[موسيقى]
نتابع من واشنطن مع مراسلنا اهلا بك معنا
جونكر يتحدث للصحفيين هذا المساء عبر
الهاتف بخصوص جديد المسيره الامريكيه التي
اسقطت في البحر الاسود ماذا قال كيربي
حول مره اخرى ان يؤكد ان الامريكيين كانوا
يحلقون في الاجواء الدوليه وفوق المياه
الدوليه واكد اكثر من مره ان الامريكيين
سوف يتابعون التحليق في هذه المنطقه اولا
لانها هذا من حقهم بحسب القانون الدولي
ثانيا لان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تعمل على حمايه امنها القومي والاهم من
هذا وذاك انه شدد اكثر من مره على ان
الامريكيين يساعدنا اوكرانيا وبالتالي
الاتهامات التي سمعناها بين مزدوجين من
روسيا حول مهمه هذه المسيره صحيحه ولكن
يعتبر الامريكينا ان من حقهم ان يفعلوا
ذلك لمساعده اوكرانيا نعم حطام المسيره
الامريكيه ما يزال في البحر الاسود وهو
يشكل مشكله للامريكيين بالنظر الى المخاوف
من ان الروس قد يستنسخون تكنولوجيا
المسيرات الامريكيه ماذا ستفعل واشنطن
بخصوص حطام الطائره
حتى الان ليس هناك اي مؤشر ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه طلبت من احدى الدول
الحليفه مثل بلغاريا او رومانيا او تركيا
ان تعمل على الوصول الى هذا الحطام في
الوقت ذاته لا يعتبر الامريكيون ان هناك
اهميه تكنولوجيه كبيره في هذه المسيره او
خطامها لان البرامج الكمبيوتر الموجوده
على هذه الطائره قد تم تدميرها قبل ان
تنزل الى البحر بالاضافه الى ذلك هم لا
يعتبرون انه سوف يكون من السهل على روسيا
ان تصل الى حتام هذه المسيره التي هي على
عمق اكثر من الف متر تحت سطح البحر نعم
المحللون في امريكا هل يرون ان هذه الازمه
ازمه اسقاط المسيره الامريكيه ذاهبه
باتجاه الاحتواء ام سيكون هناك رد امريكي
بير
الامريكيون يعتبرون ويقولون ويكررون انهم
لا يريدون نزاعا ولا يريدون ازمه ولا
يريدون تصعيدا وهذا ما قاله اليوم كيربي
وقال له امس وزير الدفاع وتقوله كل
الاداره الامريكيه ما يحاول الامريكيون ان
يقولونه هو ان هذا ليس امرا عسكريا بقدر
ما هو امر قانوني يعتبرون ان حطام هذه
الطائره هو ملكيه للحكومه الامريكيه وليس
من حق روسيا عن تصل اليه يعتبرون ان من
حقهم ان يحلقوا في الاجواء الدوليه وليس
من حق روسيا ان تعترض هذه المسيره في
الغانم شكرا جزيلا لك مباشره من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
هكذا وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ان المملكه تدعم حل الخلافات
بالحوار ومن هذا المنطلق توصلت الى
اتفاقيه مع ايران بعد جلسات في مسقط بغداد
وبكين العرب وزير الخارجيه السعودي في
كلمته خلال افتتاح المجلس الوزري لدول
التعاون الاسلامي عن تطلعه لان تنعكس
الاتفاقيه ايجابا على المنطقه
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه تؤمن باهميه
ما يجمعنا من روابط الدين والجوار وتبسط
يدها دوما للحوار يحل الخلافات بالطرق
السلميه ومن هذا المنطلق اجرت لاكثر من
عامين عده جولات للحوار على الشقاء في
ايران في كل من بغداد واسقط ثم مؤخرا في
بكين وقد تكلت هذه المباحثات بالاتفاق على
اداه الاعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
البلالين على اساس احترام مبادئ ومقاصد
ميثاق المتحده ومنظمه التعاون الاسلامي
سياده الدول وعدم التدخلة وحسن الجوار وحل
الخلافات حوار ونتطلع الى ان يعزز هذا
الاتفاق من امن واستقرار من الخليج العربي
ويدعم مسيره العمل الاسلاميه المشترك
هذا واشدد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه على دعم
المملكه المتواصل السلام في اليمن ولكل
المجهودات الداعيه لوقف اطلاق النار بشكل
دائم
ان المملكه تجدد دعمها للسلام في اليمن
ولجهود المبعوث الامني الى اليمن الراميه
الى التوصل لوقف كامل ودائما اطلاق النار
وبدء العمليه السياسيه بين الحكومه
اليمنيه والحوثيين وتؤكد على دعم مجلس
القياده الرئاسي اليمني لتمكينه من تنفيذ
سياسات ومبادرات فعاله من شانها تحقيق
الامن والاستقرار في الجمهوريه اليمنيه
وانهاء الازمه
هذا واكدى مصدر سعودي للعربيه ان
الاتفاقيه الامنيه واتفاقيه التعاون متعدد
المجالات التي تم الاتفاق على تفعيلها بين
السعوديه وايران توضح اهميه ما سيترتب على
تبادل الثقه والاحترام من فرص ايجابيه
تنعكس لفائده الشعبين وجميع شعوب المنطقه
كما شدد على ان الالتزام باحترام السياده
وعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه وحل
الخلافات بالطرق السلميه يشمل جميع الدول
العربيه والاسلاميه وعبر عن امله في اي
ينعكس هذا ايجابا على كل الملفات والازمات
في المنطقه
افادت صحيفه وسط جورنال بموافقه ايران على
وقف تصليح الحوثيين في اطار الاتفاق على
استئناف العلاقات مع السعوديه كما اشارت
الصحيفه ايضا الى ان نهج ايران حيالت صراع
في اليمن سيكون اختبارا حقيقيا لنواياها
بعد عوده العلاقات مع الرياض وان هذه
الاتفاقيه ستعطي الدفعه للتوصل الى صفقه
لانهاء النزاع في اليمن بوقت قريب
اناقش الموضوع من الرياض مع الكاتب الصحفي
ياسر الجاسر جاسر اهلا بك معنا هل تعتقد
حقا ان ايران ستوقف تسليح المليشيات
الحوثيه في اليمن كما تقول
مساء الخير اهلا بكم اذا افترضنا انه
الصوت الايراني في الداخل واحد نعم ستوقف
لا خيار امام ايران سوى ان توقف وتتخذ هذه
الخطوه ايران هي اللي كانت متلهفه للاتفاق
ولم تكن السعوديه ايران هي اللي كانت تحت
ضغط تتحرك ولم يكن امامها متنفس عدا هذا
الاتفاق هذا الاتفاق هو بوابه الخروج هو
بوابه الانقاذ لايران من ازمتها الداخليه
ومن صعوباتها الخارجيه فاذا لم تحل هذا
الاتفاق فانا بالتالي تضع نفسها في مازق
اصعب وستكون في مواجهه ليس فقط مع الرياض
ولكن هذا يدفعنا للتساؤل المشروع الايراني
منذ 79 يعني هو مشروع توسعي وزادت فيه في
السنوات الاخيره ودعمت ميليشيات مسلحه في
عديد الدول في المنطقه العربيه ما الذي
يدفعها الان للتراجع عن هذا المشروع
لنقل جانبا الجانب الاول المملكه تمكنت مع
الاصدقاء والشركاء في ايقاف بشكل كبير
عمليه الدعم للحوثي خلال الفتره الماضيه
وبشكل اكثر فاعليه وقوه من السنوات
الماضيه ايضا استطاعت المملكه في دعم
مسانده العراق في ظل الرغبه العراقيه في
التحرك والتحسن في استعاده بعض من التوازن
والتفاؤل في المستقبل النقطه الثالثه ان
ايران لم تحقق اي مكسب من خلال يعني
هيمنتها على هذه العواصم العربيه سوء مزيد
من الخسائر ومزيد
فبالتالي الخيار اليوم لدى ايران لم يعد
هذا الجانب لنقل ان الاتفاق تم بشكل اساسي
من المرشد يعني ليس يعني لا نتكلم هنا على
مستوى حكومي ادنى المرشد ونحن نتكلم هناك
صوت واحد في ايران هو صوت المرشد بالتالي
هذا ادراك ليس حبا في السلام يمكن وليس
رغبه حسن الجوار لكن
الاقتصادي رغبه في في تحسين الامور
الداخليه ام ماذا
حبا في النجاه من السقوط بعد ان تشهد يعني
ايران تتخيل مشهد 79 اليوم يحدث امامهم
المشهد الذي كان فيه هم يهبونه اليوم
الثوره المضاده وبالتالي الصعوبات التي
توجهها في الداخل اخطر بكثير اليوم قدمت
لها السعوديه خطوه جميله المملكه على فكره
في الجانب ترى جانب موضه المملكه رحبت
بهذا الاتفاق في هذا الوقت كان ممكن ان
تؤجله او تطير عامه المفاوضات بما يشكل
ضغطا على ايران طيب هنا استاذ جاسر ما
الذي يدفع كذلك السعوديه للذهاب بهذا
الاتجاه كذلك
اعاده العلاقات مع مع طهران
[موسيقى]
احسن من السكون
يعني فتح طاقه طاقه امل طاقه تفاؤل فتحت
هذه الطاقه ومده مسارها الزمني شهرين
شهرين محل الاختبار في جانبين مهمين فقط
اساسيتين قبل ان يتم اعلان استئناف
العلاقات بشكل رسمي الجهد في اليمن ومنعكس
عليه والتعاون الامني وما بعد ذلك الخطوات
الاخرى اذا تحققت انا اعتقد انه يعني في
الجانب الثاني امريكا يجب ان تكون لا خيار
امامها هذا قرار سعودي ايراني وصراحه
بمشاركه صينيه في عام الثقه مفقود في
الجوانب هذه لكن ما تحقق من الصين
والتزامها الصين ايضا وضعت يدها قالت انا
الضامن انا انا المسؤوله عن اي خلل ايراني
ولا لم يكن هذا الاتفاقيه فبالتالي هل
سيقبل الامريكيون انا اعتقد انه في جانب
مهم هذا لصالح المنطقه بالدرجه الاولى لا
يهم الرايه الامريكي كثيرا في هذه المساله
هل امريكا ترغب في الاستقرار تدعم هذا
التوجه هل ترى ان هذا ينعكس خطرا على
سياساتها مثل ما صرحت اسرائيل هذا شان اخر
لكن ما يهم المنطقه حتى ان تكون فاعله
ايجابيه ان تحاول ان تعالج ادواتها بشكلها
الخاص وبالتالي انت تستقطب اشتراكات
الخطاب الامريكي مؤيد بشكل الظاهري وداعم
لانه ايضا لا فرصته اخرى وبالتالي النتائج
التي ستحقق هل سيكون هناك انتشر بعد شهرين
هل سنقول نعم وصلنا الى نقطه كفرنا هذه
الصفحه اسقطنا الاعباء الايديولوجيه ايران
تحولت الى دوله في كلمه اخيره لانه الوقت
انتهى انت تعتقد في غضون شهرين سينضج
اتفاق حقيقي وصلب وثابت بين السعوديه
وايران
الملامح الاولى نعم تشير الى ذلك بقوه
نتمنى ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك جسر الجاسر
الكاتب الصحفي كنت تبعنا من الرياض
استقبل رئيس دوله الامارات الشيخ محمد بن
زايد ال نهيان استقبل امين المجلس الاعلى
للامن القومي الايرانيه علي شامخاني
وافادت وكاله الانباء الاماراتيه انه جرى
خلال لقاء بحث العلاقات الثنائيه وسبل مد
جسور التعاون بين البلدين في مختلف
المجالات بما يحقق المصالح المشتركه
هذا وقلم مساعد وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه
علي باقر كني ان بلاده ستوفد سفيرا لها
الى الامارات قريبا واضاف باقر كنه في
تصريحات لوكاله الانباء الايرانيه ايرنا
ان الاجراءات اللازمه لافاد السفير الى
ابو ظبي دخلت حيز التنفيذ بعد اعاده
الامارات سفيرها الى ايران واعتبر مساعد
وزير الخارجيه ان العلاقات بين ايران
والامارات لم تنقطع ابدا وانما شهدت
تراجعا في المستوى
[موسيقى]
انتهت اول جلسه استجواب لحاكم مصرف لبنان
رياض سلامه بحضور وفد القضاء الاوروبي
جلسه وصفت بالهادئه واستمرت لست ساعات
وبعد انتهاء الجلسه حدد القاضي شرب ابو
سمره صباح الجمعه موعدا جديدا لمثول سلامه
امام الوفود القضائيه الاوروبيه بتهم
تبييض الاموال والاسراء غير المشروع
غنويتي
بينما انتظر الاعلامي
ون العد
ل الذي حضر مكرها لجلسه استجواب حول
اتهامات طالته دخل سلام من باب خلفي بعيدا
عن عدسات كانت حاضره لرصده
في الداخل وفد اوروبي متسلح بمئه سؤال
رفعها قاض لبناني حفاظا على سياده الدوله
اجاب سلامي على ما طرح من اسئله في جلسه
وصفتها مصادر بالهادئه نحن بانتظار انتهاء
تحيه الاوروبي بالموضوع وبعد عوده الاوضات
الاوروبيين الى بلادهم بنشوف شو هو القرار
اللي حيتخذ هل هيعتبر انه في جرم على رياض
سلامه
اول مسؤول رفيع المستوى يخضع للاستجواب في
بلد لطالما تفلت مسؤلوه من العقاب ومرت
جرائمه الماليه والجنائيه من دون محاسبه
ومثول سلام اليوم وان كان كشاهد هو مشهد
غريب على اللبنانيين
اعتقد اللعبه وصلت الى نقطه لا رجوع فيها
رياض سلامه لا تستطيع السلطه
المنظومه ان تحميه
لان القضاء الاجنبي وضع يده ايضا على
القضيه لو تركت للقضاء المحلي
لامكن رياض سلامه ان يبقى في منصبه وان
يتابع سياسته الماليه وان يستمر في خدمه
من يحميه من اعضاء السلطه
يفضل سلامي انهاء جلساته على عجل على ان
تستكمل لاحقا مع شقيقه رجا ومساعدته مريم
الحويج غنوه يتيم العربيه
[موسيقى]
الاثيوبيه عن رفضها لتصريحات وزير
الخارجيه المصري بشان ملف سد النهضه والذي
قال فيها او التي قال فيها بان كل
الخيارات مفتوحه
واضافت ان الحل الودي مع مصر والسودان
ممكن اذا توافرت حسن النيه في المفاوضات
من جهتي اكد مساعد وزير الخارجيه المصريه
لشؤون الافريقيه محمد البدري ان قضيه سد
النهضه تمثل اولويه وجوديه تمس حياه الشعب
المصري باكمله
بعد قليل في العربيه 360 هل علاقه بين
ضفتي الاطلسي ليست كلها ورديه والدليل حرب
الطاقه الخضراء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد رفض قاضي محكمه جنائيه
في اسلام اباد تعهدا قدمه رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني السابق عمران خان لوقف العمل
بمذكره الاعتقال ضده فيما يعرف بقضيه
الهدايا وجدد القاضي قرارا المحكمه بضروره
متولي عمران خان امامها خلال الجلسه
المقبله بعد غد وكان محيط منزل خان فيلا
هور شاهد عوده الهدوء بعد تعليق قرار
اعتقاله
الان في الطريق الرئيسى المجاور لمنزل
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني عمران خان كما
ترون الحياه عادت الى طبيعتها في هذا
المكان لكن باستثناء هذا الزحام
اقف الان امام بعض الخيام التي اقامها
حزبا نصاب زعامه عمران خان لاستقبال
انصاره الذين جاؤوا هنا للتعبير عن موقفهم
وتضامنهم مع رئيس الوزراء السابق كما ترون
هنا يتواجد هنا مختلف شرائح المجتمع
الباكستاني الذين جاؤوا هنا للتعبير عن
تضامنهم مع رئيس الوزراء السابق
هذه هي البوابه الرئيسيه لمنزل رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان هنا
يحتشد العشرات من انصاره على مدار الساعه
هنا تاتي عدد من المجموعات من مختلف
المناطق الباكستانيه للتعبير عن تضامنها
مرددين متافات مؤيده لعمران خان ومناوية
للحكومه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذه خيمه الاعتصام الرئيسيه لانصار رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان بعض المعاصمين
جاؤوا من مناطق مختلفه وبعضهم يمكث هنا
منذ عده ايام دعما لرئيس الوزراء السابق
وتحسبا لاي اجراءات قد تقوم بها الشرطه
لاعتقال زعيمهم
[موسيقى]
وكما ترون يحمل العديد من انصار رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان
الهرواتي والعصي التي يقولون انها للدفاع
عن النفس ضد قمع الشرطه وبالرغم من ان
الاوضاع قد تبدو هادئه فان هذا الهدوء
ربما هو الذي يسبق العاصفه عبد الرحمن
المزيني العربيه لاهور
شكرا زياد الى تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360
الاتحاد الاوروبي يخطط لايقونه مركزا
عالميا لانتاج تقنيه الخضراء وفرض
المنافسه على واشنطن التصريح هو لي
بلومبرج التي اكدت كذلك ان اوروبا ترد
بذلك على قوانين امريكيات ووفروا دعما
سخيا للصانعين في هذا المجال قانون وصفه
رئيس الفرنسي بانه سيقسم الغرب لكن واشنطن
لم تستمع لتنطلق حرب اذا بين ضفتي الاطلسي
حرب الالواح الشمسيه والبطاريات والليثيوم
والكوبالت والقائمه تقول
وفي فيديو اليوم من عمان في وسط الصحراء
المقفره خط الفنان السويسري الفرنسي سعيد
بادواته رسما هو اقرب لرساله بين الواح
الطاقه الشمسيه يمتد الخط وراء الخط
لينتهي الى احد اطفالنا وقد اضاء مصباحه
رائع هو الرسم والاروع هي الرساله
جميله حقا صوره اليوم من مقابر اسكندرون
التركيه تحكي هذه الصوره قصه ضفتين
متقابلتين من المقابر اليسرى طبيعيه حظيه
ساكنها بالوداع اللائق والكثير من البكاء
اما اليمنى فلم يكن امام ساكنها وقت فقد
بنيت اصلا في عجل لاستيعابهم بينما لم يكن
امام ذويهم المشردين وقت كاف للبكاء تحت
كل شاهد القصه واكثرها حزنا القصص القصيره
الصغيره
[موسيقى]
اذا بهذا تنتهي العربيه 360 ولكن الفتره
الاخباريه المسائيه على العربيه مستمره
الان الى اخبار الساعه